we do see some some effects of that and
and that's very visible in in some of
the economies that have grown extremely
fast over the last two or three decades
and what you find is a countries that
used to not be extremely rich 20 30 40
years ago they have huge gaps in terms
of literacy rates still and yet when you
look at today's current enrollment
grades for example for primary secondary
tertiary education not only are women
and men equal but in many cases women
are there's greater enrollment for women
than for men and essentially what's
that's showing and then just maybe one
generation and sometimes two generations
you've got a remarkable differences in
terms of the level of education that
women are receiving
different effects for different
countries so we're covering 134
countries and not only are there
different effects for different
countries but very different effects for
different segments of society and so
while for a certain segment of society
the the idea of a man session may be
true it's not true for four other parts
of society and so it's it's going to
have very very different effects I think
one of the most probably the most
worrying effects is the the fact that
there will be less to go around in terms
of resources and that can be attributed
to girls and women's education and
empowerment and certainly when we think
about if we've got less resources and
we've got to think just a little bit
harder about what would be the most
effective way of investing those
resources and it really does come down
to girls education and investing in that
because it has enormous multiplier
effects